au petit soin pour ce sportif de haut
niveau
un animal pas comme les autres le cheval
ici des trotteurs ou des galopeurs
entraîneurs jockeys drivers
propriétaires maréchal ferrant notamment
pour l'encadrer et ce tous les jours ce
dimanche l'hippodrome de carrère devrait
retrouver l'ambiance d'avant ou presque
avec la réouverture au public
mais les mesures barrières face au co
vite 19 reste d'actualité
les gestes barrière avec de sécurité
qu'il faut avec la tribune en h et on a
fait des dons à partager la tribune m
places co2 pour que les gens qui s'y
passera pas trop connue et que l'on
puisse respecter le cahier des charges
que la fédération nous a envoyé le massé
est recommandé vivement recommandé pas
forcément obligatoire mais recommandée
mais pour nous tous les personnels de
l'hippodrome
le masque est obligatoire quant au
jockey ou driver
ils ont d'ores et déjà pris l'habitude
du masque durant la course commencé les
courses en guadeloupe depuis fin mai on
a enfin mentionné conjoint donc bien sûr
obligations du masque c'est vraiment
difficile pour avoir la chaleur la
première course on ressent vraiment être
mal à l'aise avec le masque après c'est
comme tout on est obligé de s'y habituer
d'ivoire ça m'a pas gêné plutôt qu'un
joueur parle sagem
il faut rester toujours coût de la
maladie en collation une réouverture
gratuite pour le public
la première course est prévue à 11
heures mais pas de paris pour le moment
pour cela il faudra attendre le mois
d'août ou septembre